[Music]
hey what's going on everybody it's Sean
Evans coming at you from Los Angeles
where I'm taking a little break from hot
one but not for meeting spicy ass
chicken
we're here at Howland raised in
Chinatown where chef Johnny zona and his
wife Amanda are cooking up some of the
spiciest Nashville style fried chicken
in the city maybe the country possibly
even the world there are our long lines
for this stuff every single day and
people will not stop hitting me up about
trying it out for myself
so I'm here to eat some lunch because
God forbid I take a weekend off let's go
[Music]
are you doing chef good I do it thanks
for having me not a problem guys we got
Shawn in the house hey can you start by
odd talking to me about national fried
chicken what it is and how it ended up
in LA national hot chicken is a dish
that kind of like goes way back to like
the 20s and and kind of like the prints
family it's a dish kind of based on
revenge a wife is trying to get a
drive-in you know and really light them
up but ended up liking it opened up a
restaurant his friends started liking it
and it kind of caught on
can you talk too about the chicken here
at Howlin rays and I don't want to talk
about spice first I want to talk about
the actual chicken can you talk to me
about how you guys make the actual
chicken so we use a great local chicken
that they actually put them to sleep
before they're slaughtered so that it
makes a little more tender that way I
know it's like you're like how can you
say that you know but it's like it's
true what's also different on in terms
of the hell and racing is we're keeping
it so close to coming straight out of
the fryer and being served that
literally like you bite into a beast and
it's like steaming and now let's talk
about spice because there's levels to
this right there's six advertised heat
level there is a seventh for people that
really want to ruin their day like
yourself and we don't advertise that the
mile is going to have just like a dash
cayenne and then you work your way to
your medium and it's got a little bit
more of that Cayenne a little bit of
ghost pepper you know but a very small
amount then you go you're to the hot and
that's that's the ghost in the habanero
we're adding a point a bit more of that
then you work your way to your extra hot
and all of a sudden Trinidad scorpion
incorporated and then you go through
your Halen and it's just you know it's
loaded with the Carolina Reaper loaded
with it
scorpion and it it has those peppers to
base off of from the mild to medium to
hot and then it just has those on top of
it so this should probably not come as a
surprise to anybody but we're going to
do wings I have a very special friend
with me today so I'll get a bigger order
I want to go how about we go
um an extra-hot on the wings a-howlin on
the wings and then i want you to give me
that sort of backroom special the top
secret how round was that nobody knows
about well you know that we love to
share the pain here on first we feast so
i'm joined for lunch by comedian brian
read ban low you know him from death
squad you known from the Joe Rogan
experience and today we'll find out how
he is with very very very spicy chicken
yeah this looks scary you have any hot
sauce experience I used to like work at
this restaurant and the chef had like
the liquid rage one that you guys use
yeah hot one and so I would always put
it on my finger because I was a waiter
and then wait for like another waiter to
be at a table taking an order and just
walk by and put it on their lips
and just watch them that was my fun
thing but other than that hot sauce I
never really did the dance and insane
stuff but I always have been a hot sauce
fan why is it the funniest thing when
people are dying on hot sauce because
you know what they're going through the
pain they're going through you know it's
like when you watch a prank video
because you know it's not happening to
you but you can watch somebody else
suffer I think I feel like we're going
to suffer a lot yeah are you ready to
suffer it you know that a place is
serious about their hot food when they
include surgical glove I know with your
order you want these are sight well I
can I just smell one there you go yeah
all right yeah I like how you're the one
wearing the glove
all right let's start - and then these
are serious there's no hiding from this
yeah all right there we go mmm got it
really good
oh here it is it's a good flavor though
this is such a good chicken wing but it
scares me a little bit yeah I already a
make your eyes water
and then look like is my water I'm gonna
have issue this is the hottest one that
they make that they make also really
good oh wow
I really like the taste now I'm I wish
we started off with a nice baby one
right because I'm kind of hungry and I
didn't eat cause of my car I'm having
lunch of red van so I'll chill how would
anyone eat that though like eat the
whole thing no one can eat the whole
thing of that I don't think so like it
takes a champion to just take a bite of
this look at that before we go on to
number three I would like to point out
red band it's a quick lunch but it's an
epic lunch we're on now to the last of
our wings
it is the Howell plus it is the secret
backroom sign a waiver you might die
wing how you feeling how you doing my
mouth was on fire all right
oh that's not that bad absolutely and I
feel like that one was hotter
all right maybe I'm wrong noon is your
way wrong hello all hot sauces all
peppers are kind of different they all
hit you differently and that one believe
yeah red BAM the wings that we're eating
today but if this room
hotter than the wings of Blair's
Megadeth's off of the good Ranger we're
on a whole new level and I would say
this at this point I kind of get the
psychedelic high off hot sauce I kind of
get it right now I'm swimming uh-huh
like I feel like I'm on a drug a little
I feel my heart beat my eyebrows the
same with me it's like a little wavy
like you're kind of bound huh one more
bite and then I'm then I'm getting in an
uber ah what red band it was really nice
to meet you
[Music]
I don't even know how to
there's no no graceful way to end it
hi for watching
[Music]
Wow